anxiety did you have going into
something you ain't never done before
like like for the job interview or
something I wasn't anxious because I was
like I didn't really expect again
he doesn't expect to get it at the job
you're like who me
yeah all right basically I went in there
with the thing of like
best scenario here is I get to say I
worked in a in a game company for like
six months before
that right on the resume
what that was yeah
um but then when I was in there I would
you know I think like it was like pretty
much every day I was like oh I don't
know I don't know what I'm doing so like
I'm gonna get fired tomorrow
every day for the first yeah six months
but um but yeah like it you know